Анексія українського Криму Росією, війна на Донбасі,
вторгнення російських збройних сил у повітряний
і підводний простір Швеції.
Ці дії Кремля підштовхнули шведів до відновлення призову
на військову службу у 2017 році через 7 років після її скасування.
Також зазвичай спокійна Швеція торік провела
наймасштабніші військові навчання за останні 23 роки.
Вперше за десятиліття шведи розмістили війська на
острові Готланд – у найбільш східній точці країни.
Напад Росії на Швецію може бути подібним до нападу на Україну
із використанням прихованих військ та психологічної зброї.
Росія може захопити наш острів Готланд або
стратегічні позиції на східному узбережжі Швеції.
У Стокгольмі серйозно ставляться до брязкання російської зброї.
Уряд надрукував 5 мільйонів брошур-довідників
про те, як приготуватись до воєнного конфлікту.
"Якщо прийде криза або війна" – так називаються брошури,
які отримають шведські родини поштою.
У них пояснено, як діяти у разі стихійних лих, кібератак або війни.
Радіо має велике значення
і я переконана, що люди забули про це.
Потрібне радіо, яке працює не від струму, а на батарейках.
Ось це наприклад, я можу зарядити від
сонячної енергії і воно також має ліхтар.
Так я можу отримати усю необхідну інформацію.
В роки "холодної війни" у Швеції побудували 65 тисяч бомбосховищ.
Зараз інспектують їхній стан. Брошура також
містить детальну інструкцію про те, де перебуває
найближче бомбосховище,
якими продуктами запастися і де взяти воду.
Рибні фрикадельки - дуже непогані.
Може це і не найсмачніша їжа, однак їх можна їсти
холодними, якщо треба, і вони зберігаються пару років.
Поки деякі особливо занепокоєні шведи підбирають консерви,
уряд на чолі із соціал-демократами вже підписав
угоду про співпрацю з НАТО, яка у разі конфлікту
полегшить доступ військ Альянсу на територію Швеції.
А опозиція звернулася до уряду з ініціативою вступу до НАТО.